so the topic today
is
should modern women settle
so are you guys aware of the 80 20 rule
when it comes to dating
no no so i think you guys you're more
familiar with the content you might
right yes okay so if you ask 80 of women
what they look for in a guy
they list out 20 of men sometimes less
so the reason a lot of times girls will
say things like men or trash men are the
worst is because um they're all sleeping
with the same ones
they say that 20 of men have sexual
access to 80 of women
yeah so um and there there's numbers
that back this up like for example men
swipe right on tinder 46 percent of the
time
and
what percent of the time do you think
women swipe right on tinder
i think that's why i've left
no i i know so what percent of the time
as a girl percentage of that i think
like yeah half of that twenty-five
percent you think yeah
maybe five five percent five
so there's a bunch there's a bunch of
different studies and
different ones will say different things
but the the most recent one i found is
women's swipe right 14 of the time oh
but i i have seen it as low as five
before because when you think about it
that's just them swiping right that
doesn't include like what percent do
they go on a date with sure okay right
right so the question is
oh and then on top of that sorry second
part
is um half of women over 30 are single
and childless
so knowing what we know right there's
not enough men to go around that the
women want
so my question is should women
settle
no
okay no no why do you guys why
i mean
in this day and age especially as
dancers for us
no having a kid
kind of halts your dance career yeah and
and
because like and that to me and all of
that stuff for guys they can do whatever
the hell they want you know they can
um
but as women we don't get that privilege
so
well what does the biological clock have
to do with settling i just don't
understand that
i think
well
for women settling is having kids
getting married having a family right
yeah and so in order to do all of that
mainly i'm thinking about the family
thing
we
once you have a family we have to
provide for that child for the whole
their whole lives whereas
men don't really have to do that they
can do what they want and then leave
no not well they're on the hook for
child support for 18 years
if they want to pay yeah
well you can't you can go to jail if you
don't pay child support yeah
i'm sorry may i say um
i found it interesting that you read the
question as should women settle down as
in get married have children and have a
life with a partner
i thought the question was around should
women settle for a man that they believe
to be less valuable than they themselves
are yeah
that's how i was yeah that's how i
started but hold on if i may just say
i'm astonished that you would say
that women should not settle down and
get married and have children in general
that to me i find perplexing i'm saying
as a dancer as a dancer okay
but is that not something that is
something that would give the vast
majority of women
including dancers some sense of purpose
i think some sense i think anything i
think in terms of dances it would
literally stop our whole career because
even say like we have
like 35 shows going on like whatever
like in our in our calendar or our
schedule if that happens she won't
really
i understand but the careers of athletes
as as is similar for dancers is limited
yeah how long are you going to be how
long are you going to be dancing for
as long as
long as you can and i wish you you know
good luck with that but at the end of
that
do you consider like having children
having a partner oh 100. yeah i think it
depends when we want to stop like if i
have a kid and i feel like that's the
right time then obviously then i'm like
oh i'm ready to start a family and i'm
ready to do what i can but if it's in
the wrong time if it's really unexpected
then like it's really it's a shock you
know what i'm saying so
during that time i would have no choice
then to
have my child and i'll have to maybe
give up my career are you all dancers
yeah okay okay um i'm interested to know
as to whether you think that it's best
to perhaps settle down after
your career as dancers
because
at what age would that career end is it
in your early 30s is it in your late 30s
perhaps in your 40s oh basically my six
days i sincerely hope that that's the
case for you too
but
if you're thinking that you want to get
married at the end of your career i'm
sure you don't want to get married at 60
you might want to get married a little
bit earlier yeah did you know 90 of your
eggs are gone by 30
90
and did you know that geriatric
pregnancy starts at 35
and even if you do ivf do you do you
know how much that costs if you want to
do ivf yeah
it's 25k goodness me and that may not
even work
so so why do you think we tell women to
prioritize like why would you tell girls
to prioritize a career over a family
when if you wait too long to have a
family then you can't have one
i mean
for me personally i feel like it's
completely up to the person yeah but for
me personally i'm not even sure if i
want kids i don't know i don't want to
get married i do want to have a partner
and i'd like to live with them but
for me yeah i prioritize my career
because i've never been in a
relationship it's never really worked
out for me so i don't see why that needs
to be a priority for me
maybe if i'd been in a relationship
before maybe i would see that as more of
a path but
my upbringing and the way my life has
gone that is not a priority for me my
career is because that's where i can put
all my energy
and my effort but i would never say to
someone
um you have to have children before 30
or you have to have children after 30
you have to prioritize your creates
completely up to you no i agree i think
people should choose what they want to
choose but we should be aware of the
consequences
so single single childless women over
the age of 45 are statistically the
least happy
is that really a shock though is that a
shock like i mean you think about it you
can't undo our biology
so as much as like you know the times
have changed like our biology still
makes us want to have children
so i think
a lot of times girls prioritize their
their career when they're young and they
don't realize it they they might not
have the option to have a partner or a
children later
yeah it's true i feel like it just
depends on the person and
if they want to go down that path
because
once you get a partner it's like it's a
commitment as well so this is like okay
cool enough to juggle two things at the
same time which is probably why they
like don't want to
have a relationship during their career
yeah but
yeah but going on or what you said i've
seen
a lot of dances like not a lot let me
chill like i've seen i've seen some
dancers and choreographers have like
kids and they've obviously taken a break
but then they will always come back yeah
yeah i don't see nothing wrong with just
taking a break in your career if that's
the case if you do have a partner yeah i
think if a break can come back to the
type of thing yeah spend time with your
family yeah and like janet jackson oh
she's a queen of pop obviously and she
had a kid like that's that's different
but i think still as a dancer in in the
industry i think you used to have a
child and still do both we're like why
can't you do both
you know well i think it's just that
everything comes at a cost
yeah so so if you take a break like
you're not going to out-compete the
girls that didn't yeah yeah and so it's
good it's going to affect your career
but if you don't prioritize family you
might not be able to have one later yeah
so
it's kind of like a double edge you
can't have everything
um so question for you guys do you guys
have um a height requirement that you
have to date a guy no i do now you do
okay so go around like tell me what your
minimum standards are to date a guy
like what you look for i wouldn't have a
height requirement but i would prefer to
be with a guy that's taller than me or
at least my height okay which is
i'm five eight okay i have eight or
taller okay
yeah i i i agree but then i end up
getting dating guys who are eye level
yeah same and then it's like um no
you're disrespectful so i prefer to date
a guy who's taller than me yeah
are there any other standards like money
requirements or no you don't care about
money no
um
i don't mind actually i've actually
spoken to people my height or like a bit
shorter but um
yeah i don't mind the height
and
what else do i like
what are the standards
let's turn out let's come up
but then the ones who i live without the
most disrespectful ones
i'm sorry
the only ones have the most
vim to say and it's like is that the
minute
the minute the minute i speak active the
minute i speak i'm crazy
is it that you find
a taller brother that might be showing
the same kind of mad behavior you don't
you'll accept that from a taller guy no
i didn't say that
nobody
that's why i'm asking yeah no is that
what the case is so no no no so the from
for me from what i've come across the
guys shorter men are more disrespectful
oh of course
[Laughter]
but the guys who have come across who
are taller than me they have i don't
know i don't know what it is but they
just have more respect and that's the
ones who i've come across and
they they i think they know their
boundaries with some women okay you know
why do you think that is like the taller
guys in your experience are like more
respectful or kinder or what do you what
do you think it is the difference
between the shorter men and the people i
think they've i think i've spent more
time with them not that i haven't spent
more time with the ones who are high
level but i feel like they don't
understand and they don't limit their
boundaries with what with sometimes with
what they say okay because i feel like
sometimes with what like with what guys
say they don't really care even though
they're seeing that woman and it's like
oh oh like oh she should know she should
know i'm joking she should know this and
she should know that and it's like no
and it's like
the tall guys that i've seen like for me
personally
they already like
set a boundary with me and them so they
should know what to say when not to say
it like they're not disrespectful do you
know what i mean don't get wrong some
two guys are just some two guys listen
oh yeah true true
some men are disrespectful
yeah i feel like yeah i feel like i feel
like it's mixed anyway i feel like well
it just depends who it is one thing one
thing i will say to you over here one
thing i'll say to you is i think your
disparity is more so that
you don't respect the short guys and
therefore you'll find that when they say
something rude to you it's like who the
hell are you to speak to me as a tall
guy
which may be your type as such if he's
disrespectful oh he's putting me in my
place i understand why
that's true though
how can you tell me
all short guys are disrespectful and you
find that most tour guides are not but
then she said don't get twisted which i
agree on because some because
some men anyway some in any way are
disrespectful anyway so this is what i'm
saying like i haven't really dated as
much like
when you sometimes when you talk to like
like different sort of guys like they
can come across as like the same someone
can come some of them can come across as
different so it just depends that's what
i'm saying it just depends on who the
guy is i'm not saying all short men are
just level you know what i mean but yeah
just depends who they are it just really
depends who they are what percent of men
do you think are six foot and taller
okay this is a hot one in the uk or uk
yeah or in the world um
actually i don't know i think it's i
think it's in the in in the world oh oh
that's a lot then 25
yeah do you think i don't really think
it's that less i don't know you know
i think it's sure
oh
so it goes it goes back to it goes back
to what i was saying earlier the reason
women say things like men like if a girl
says men are trash men are trash men are
trashed it typically means i've been ran
through by a bunch of guys that didn't
want me
oh yeah yeah that's true yeah and it's
like typically because only 15 of men
are six foot
so typically she's dating a guy that's
too hot for her and it's out of her
league and none of her friends are nice
enough to tell her you're screwing the
guy that's out of your league and maybe
you should get a guy on your level but
the other guy will screw you but he'll
never wife you